have you guys ever had a good british
kind of fry up
in japan no no no no still not found
anywhere that does it
i found fish and chips but like that's
like the one thing i can't find
you found good fish and chips fish chips
are [ __ ] fish and chips are so boring
it is english breakfast i want a home
got one right goblin yeah
it's all right that's probably the best
one i've had it's pretty good yeah
really
yeah but like i'm i'm not crazy i'm
never going to
choose fish and chips you know like yeah
either
you've got some of the best fish like
dishes here in japan yeah yeah
you look at that you're like you know
what [ __ ] this i feel like fish and
chips
i feel like i'm expected to eat it
because all my years here right
whenever i go oh yeah i'm from the uk oh
everyone's one of three things it's like
oh yeah
david or all the spice girls fish and
chips
it's like it was one of the few things
about british culture so i'm kind of
like
i should probably enjoy anything else
what like british cuisine
crisp sandwich baked beans bread
sandwich sunday roast
oh sunday right yeah is there is there a
sunday roast place in japan yes
hobgoblin is not really good one big
advert
it is good basically just good goblin
apparently yeah and you'll probably bump
into us there because we get there yeah
quite a lot yeah genuinely [ __ ] but uh
yeah no british food's hard to come by
unfortunately sausage rolls
greg's i do miss greg's actually if it's
a franchise couldn't you just buy one
and bring it here
i don't think it's the first one tastes
great
unless it's like one pound like it has
to be cheap as [ __ ] like if it greg's is
for you make it a hundred yen right yeah
there's no way you could get the cost do
it
oh my god
[Laughter]
you've got a studio the size of spain
right you can you can get a greg's
digital that's how you make your first
meal bringing grapes
anything else you missed about england
that you like
that you crave boris johnson
[Laughter]
obviously and here comes all the
dislikes finally you can you can be in
my corner in this one
because i've had arguments with them
where there's always a slippery slope
tries to get you on side about anything
well i i have to argue with these boys
because their like tokyo architecture is
amazing i know that you
are up with me where you think like
london is just beautiful the
architecture is amazing it is
yeah objectively and these boys are like
no it's boring it's boring it's all the
same
well i mean look at this district here
look out the window you know there's no
interesting architectural buildings i
kind of like the
the feel of japan it feels like one big
theme park because everything's kind of
clean the building's
made out of some sort of weird woody
plastic material
it just feels like a theme park almost
but it looks ugly it looks great
it looks great japan japan is literally
one of the most aesthetics
like countries in all those areas look
really cool but when you start going
like 10 minutes out of center it all
just starts to look like an amalgamation
of just
doesn't every country look like that no
no no [ __ ]
every country got a [ __ ] croydon i i
beg to differ sir
every country you go every every country
you go 10 minutes out of the city center
and it all looks the same in the uk the
high is very high and the lows are very
low yeah and low it's croydon in terms
of design it's a lovely place the people
are great
i love croydon but yeah shout out to
croydon
jokingly before natsuki came to uk i
said where do you want to go in the uk
the most
uh croydon how do you know what that is
obviously like one of the most
depressing places
possibly been to my life he's still yet
to go yeah why does he want to go
croydon no you have to deal with
i don't know how did he learn he must
have been it must have been like a bad
thing
or he heard it like from you maybe one
time no i know that sounds like a place
i don't i don't sit in
north japan talking about croydon